around a hundred years ago something
really exciting was happening an age-old
philosophical question what is the limit
of knowledge collided with a modern
mathematical one can knowledge be
mechanized and this gave birth to a new
field computer science the science of
computation the dream of mechanizing
human knowledge was inspired by
developments over 300 years ago during
the early stages of the Industrial
Revolution factories were being
developed as industrialists began to
explore mass production and the
mechanization of labour gradually
machines were designed to replicate
human action but replicating human
mental processes remain the stuff of
dreams and this began to change with the
development of machines that could add
multiply and eventually make decisions
at first even the most advanced machines
were limited to one specific task if you
needed something else done you had to
build a new machine however around 200
years ago a great industrialist thinker
Charles Babbage was dreaming of a
general symbolic machine one that could
answer complex questions by breaking
them down into smaller questions of
logic and arithmetic and essentially
braiding them together
his final dream was never realized but
his driving question remained was it
possible to build the general machine
that could answer any question now by
the 1900's mathematicians and
philosophers were posing this question
in different ways mathematicians asked
what are mechanical machines capable of
how powerful could they be
while philosophers asked what are the
limitations of mechanical machines
what will machines never do and in 1936
Alan Turing bridge this divide with a
paper which revolutionized our
understanding about what machines can
and cannot do he outlined blueprints for
what he called a universal machine a
machine that could answer anything that
was answerable part of his great insight
was that the power of the universal
machine would always reside in the
instructions it followed later known as
software not the physical design of the
machine or Hardware and using a simple
language his machine would run any
instructions that you could imagine and
the year after Turing's paper a young
Claude Shannon completed a master's
thesis describing a clever inside he had
about telephone relays he realized he
could arrange electrical switches in
various ways to perform the fundamental
operations of logic automatically using
electricity suddenly it was practically
possible to build the universal computer
powered by electrical clocks that buzzed
away at near the speed of light and
followed any instructions you provide
in the decades to follow computing
machines grew in their speed of
operation and memory capacity suddenly
many hard questions humans faced became
easy or very practical for computers to
answer quickly but deeper problems
emerged there seemed to be a growing set
of seemingly easy problems such as as a
given number Prime that were computable
on our machines but took so long when
the questions were large such as is 140
trillion trillion trillion plus one
prime that it could take thousands or
even millions of years for the computer
to give you an answer or halt so these
problems were practically impossible to
solve think of these as heart problems
and people consider drawing a line in
the sand between problems that were easy
practical to solve and problems that
were hard practically impossible to
solve and the attempt to precisely
define this division of easy and hard
practical and impractical problems leads
to the most important unsolved question
in computer science today
what makes hard problems hard is it a
result of some underlying mathematical
pattern or is the perception of hardness
merely an illusion will new insights
make these hard problems easy and this
question is not just an intellectual
curiosity the backbone of the Internet
depends on a set of problems being out
of reach or practically impossible for
our machines but to begin we must go way
back in time and revisit the mythology
of ancient Oracle's first we'll explore
what knowledge is and what it means to
think
to compute